[Music]
when i was in high school my best friend
in the world was brian rau
he lived in like the cool house a house
where his parents were
great parents but occasionally they go
out of town and they would set certain
parameters wherein he could have some
people over well that was a really
long-winded way of saying he had parties
at his house a lot
no disrespect to his parents no i know
but it's just like every every hou
there's always it wasn't like one of
those houses where the parents were just
like negligent they don't know
they were not negligent they were very
good parents but they were um they
allowed him to have people over but so
it ended up being the party party
yeah and um it was so fun we had so so
much fun there uh and christian went you
came for the it was the first time you
were there i believe i was a sophomore
in high school it was the first time i
ever had more than one beer i think i
had three beers as a matter of fact i
should point out that you lo we both did
but as a sophomore you look like you
were maybe nine or ten years old yeah
and so it's the first time i i would say
i got buzzed from alcohol and
i thought it would it would be a good
idea at that party with all these older
kids older girls
wanting to impress i went across the
street to a gas station and i thought
it'd be a good idea to buy about 24 to
30 packs of skittles which to you it was
still like exciting to buy candy on your
own yes so i brought the bushel of
skittles
back to the party and i started
giving them out to people i think
specifically girls
they thought it was i was cute and sweet
and they're like oh that's so nice
skittles and who doesn't like skittles
it doesn't have the desired effect i
don't think
what was the desired effect i wanted
them to like me how much well i think
they ended up liking me in a very
different way yeah life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your skittles loving host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my brother who
to this day you don't both have to love
skittles
you don't both have to want to taste the
rainbow fruit flavors
um yeah you uh
i can see in your brain
that be and by the way it's still a nice
thing to do you'd probably still do that
to engender yourself with people i guess
so but i i don't remember what my
specific motivation was i just think i
wanted to
um you wanted to get right
impressed i didn't have any ulterior
motives i didn't want to like find a
girl and like impress her with skittles
and bring her home to our parents house
or something
i don't think i was thinking that far
ahead i was just thinking
i just wanted people to like me look at
that age it's like you are you
so desire these i mean we're
we've got hormones raging and like
that's the number one pursuit yes and
we're we were all
insecure at one point and we all felt
alienated at one point and
um our guest today i don't know if he
was at this particular party i don't
remember that i think he probably but he
could have been
yeah i would imagine he was because he
was friends with our that group um and
it's
through brian rau and my friend jeff and
mike i met uh our guest today
uh and i'm so glad i did they introduced
me to a lot of people that i'm grateful
for but uh our guest today is
james blake
who tennis fans will know as uh one of
the best of the last
20 years former number one ranked us
tennis player and number four in the
world in the world that's crazy that
nuts yeah i said that
yeah well we would get into that but not
as much as i would have liked my time
with james was unfortunately limited
he's got a family he's been very busy
lately but um
yeah when i met him he was a sophomore i
was a junior in high school he was a
sophomore we were in the same math class
uh so he was advanced
he was it was actually an advanced math
class so james was very advanced uh to
be in this advanced math class for a
junior and as a sophomore but he was the
he was the little guy and like i was a
little guy in high school so maybe that
was part of the reason i i bonded with
him but um he i don't know how to say
this and james knows this so it's uh you
know
but i don't know how else to say it he
was kind of like
i i really liked him we were all part of
the same group but um he didn't he
didn't drive i mean at that age like
being 15 as opposed to 16 was the number
one difference was
he could not drive drive so he relied on
us for rides places so he was always
like hey guys are you going to the party
and we're like yeah we're going to the
party's like uh and can i get a ride
about a year later he
sprouted he went through a crazy growth
spurt and became like the hunkiest of
hunks in
in our town he was like
uh yeah he was just like the hunkiest um
and and like by far the best athlete oh
yeah he was
uh in the in the country well i know but
at the time in high school because i was
you were a year older i was a couple
years younger than him and i remember
my high school i went to we both went to
um
fairfield prep which is a catholic
all-boys school
in fairfield and and you spend one
semester at fairfield high school the
public school where james went but i
remember at prep
we had a very good tennis team we had we
want our school we i say we but i wasn't
on the team uh we won the state
championship like most years we were
really really good that's right and
every time we played fairfield high
school in tennis
uh
i'm pretty sure our team would win we
would like dominate fairfield high
school except
for the number one singles matchup which
was always our best player against james
blake and james blake would
like you didn't have a chance against
him he dominated tennis it would like
make the local news if somebody won a
game off yeah it was ridiculous yeah and
then he became the best in the state and
then he became the best in new england
and and then he went to harvard and
became the best in college and then he
went on to be a pro and became the best
in the country and so
crazy story when we were and we're all
around the same age when we were
following we of course we followed very
closely james's career we were friends
and and i remember when he played agassi
uh was it the u.s open it was yes 2005.
he was the quarterfinals the us open and
i remember watching it with you yeah in
santa monica and
i've never felt like i i get really into
sports specifically the jets and i i've
been crushed emotionally watching sports
in my life but i've never been
more into any sporting event than i was
that night yeah we were we i've never
been so
invested yeah yeah we were connected as
a our friend was like it was the
craziest thing and also not just that we
know him but it ended up being it that
match goes down in tennis history like
people still talk about that match as a
classic like an all-time class well it
also was the the stakes were heightened
for for everybody in every in every way
in uh just the drama of it was so
intense because james had lost his
father about a year earlier i think and
he had struggled with
uh
his horrible injury
back the year before yeah he was at a
really tough year
i mean understatement
yeah i mean he was down for the count
and and so then to come back in such uh
such a huge way such a grand way and um
against the best in the country it was
like the world it was an amazing
redemption story and
and then um
for those who don't know about five
years ago now 2015 a couple years after
james retired from pro tennis after
being the celebrated incredible
figure yeah he had
an incident in new york city where he
was falsely
he talks about in the interview but
basically he was falsely accused um of a
crime by a cop and he was on videotape
uh tackled to the ground and put in
handcuffs and plain clothes cop no
questions asked tackled him
uh knee in the back um in front of
well we talk about it so we don't want
to get too into it but uh
but that's basically that's one of the
reasons we
specifically wanted to talk to him this
week we've we've wanted to talk to him
for a while now but specifically this
week in light of everything that's
happening
in the country in the world um we
thought it would be good to hear from
him as uh as an african-american
man who's had um an incident that um
that is somewhat similar to what we saw
with uh george floyd and and and has a
life of smaller incidents uh which he
talks about uh yeah we were just very
eager to have that we've been wanting to
have that conversation as as i i know
all of hopefully all of you have been um
but we are
very we are ill-equipped to have it as
as two white men um so we thought that
sorry yeah we thought this would be a
good opportunity to listen to someone
who has gone through it and is a friend
and yeah and um has gone through it like
you said throughout his whole life yes
to some extent so i hope you enjoy
listening along with us to
the great
uh tennis champion
and dear friend old friend
james blake
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet
again i was a nerd uh
you were somewhat of a nerd right like
yeah but you were both uh see i always
see like at the time and i grew up on as
did you on like 80s
comedies where there was a clear
distinction between
the nerds and the jocks and and they
didn't bleed into each other
right anyway but you were an athletic
studious kid is that fair to say yeah i
mean but it's still athletic it was i
was a tennis player so it wasn't like i
was the star quarterback you know i
wasn't uh right i definitely wasn't the
ac slater although i mean as much as he
was cool and the athlete he was a
wrestler which i don't feel like in
normal like in most high schools that's
looked upon as the you know that big man
on campus uh i think it what my my buddy
togo would say differently at his school
in outside of uh boston the wrestlers
were according to him there was they
were like the cool ones um really and
was i'm gonna go on a limb and say he
was arrested
how did you know
and what did get you into tennis i mean
i i as well as i know you i don't think
i've ever asked you that
so both my parents played um just for
fun they play with each other and so i
always joked with them that they were
too cheap to pay for a babysitter so
they'd bring me and my brother up to
watch them and we just kind of got into
it and wanted to be like them and that
was like our family thing you know
sunday afternoons was play dinos with
the family no kidding when we were in
school together your brother what he was
he was like a big man on campus
yeah well i was always in his shadow he
was the tall you know ridiculously smart
going on you were literally in a shadow
really yeah really athletic and so he
was he was kind of the big man uh a
little bit the big man on campus he was
just very very popular yeah
didn't quite trickle down to me as as
much but um yeah i tried well i i wonder
if how much of it had to do with i mean
i was small going to high school i
talked about that way too often on the
show uh i very realize i had very little
to talk about when i'm like oh you guys
know i was really tiny right you
remember how tiny i remember how small i
was yeah i was four nine and i weighed
89 pounds no way in freshman year i was
five i was five feet eighty-five pounds
wow
wow
85 pounds or nine wow yeah yeah i was
little um i guess pudgier than you
uh
and then when did you grow james it was
was it senior year
it was junior to senior year i started
junior year i was still little junior
year junior year i was i started junior
five three and i started senior year six
foot wow oh my god i grew nine inches in
one year do you remember what that was
like like do you remember what your i
didn't fall it was like yeah
my knees were killing me really but yes
i do remember coming back senior year
and being like wow wait a minute what's
going on like there's
that girl that was ignoring me is now
like talking to me she's what happened
there like i'm used to going i would
used to i used to go to parties and sit
there and you know hang with the guys
and before i knew it there were like
girls around us like
what happened what changed i remember i
don't know if i saw you first because
then i switched schools and um yeah i
remember hearing i remember start
starting to hear chatter like james
blake is hot i remember like i just it
just like bled into the social strategy
our town is not that big um
it was a small town yeah so you noticed
a change then socially but uh
what about and what about in terms of
tennis in terms of people talking to you
like this was going to be a career this
was going to be
something that you could do for money
when did that yeah my life kind of
changed quite a bit in those couple of
years it was amazing how quickly
everything went and it was almost too
fast for me to even recognize because i
went from being
you know i was athletic for high school
and i was a very good high school player
i was a very good player in new england
but when i finally grew i went from
being a good player in new england to um
one of the best players in the country
yeah
and so then when i was one of the best
players in the country
um
agents started taking notice
college coaches were obviously taking
notice and then um i still thought my
next step was gonna be okay college
hopefully i can be a pretty good college
player i didn't realize how quickly i'd
started improving when i was growing um
to the point where agents were talking
about me turning pro right away straight
out of high school or what i should you
know playing in the us open all those
kind of things so i was just really
um
behind like i was just naive to how um
how quickly things had changed um
because yeah it was all right in that
time from about 16 until 19. um those
years were um my growth in terms of
tennis
maturity strength physical everything
kind of happened pretty quickly there so
james you thought about at that point
going pro that early like before college
i couldn't believe there were agents
even talking about that because i
thought so that's where i was just so
behind i didn't realize in my mind the
difference between what i was doing and
what pros were doing was
you know astronomical there's such a
wide gap and i thought you know they're
just incredible they're out of this
world i couldn't ever play with them and
i still thought the college players were
much better than me yeah and so i
thought no there's no chance i'm not
ready to go to go pro and i got to
college and i thought
you know i was still living in the
shadow of my brother he was three years
older than me he was in college he was
all-american you went to the same man
you followed him to harvard yeah at
harvard so same school and i thought in
my mind he was always so much bigger and
stronger and better than me and now i've
finally grown i've caught up to him a
little bit and then everyone i assumed
he was gonna play number one and i was
gonna play three or four or five on the
team and when i got to school everyone
was joking you know that same chatter
was who's gonna play number one james or
thomas my brother and i was like are you
kidding me he's beaten me my whole life
like i can't ever beat him
and
you know before i knew it i was
like top 10 in the country and i thought
i was going to be four or five on the
team and so all these things happened
quickly and that was freshman year
started kind of keeping my toe in the
water of the pro game that first summer
my summer between freshman and sophomore
year okay so you
so you knew did you have a long term
plan like okay i mean in the long term
in the sense of uh you knew you were
going to stay in college at least for
the duration
my long-term plan was getting a harvard
degree i thought i was going to do that
and so i went for my first year and then
when i was coming back for my second
year that's when i said okay this is
going to be my year to make a decision
you know i'm either going to go pro
after this year after my sophomore year
i'm going to turn pro if i feel like i
can't get any better and i'm ready to go
or i'm going to stay and go all four
years to college i wasn't going to go
three it turned out that that year i had
a lot of success i did well i was number
one in the country and it made sense for
me to to go pro and turn it after my
sophomore year what was that because we
both have brothers and we've talked a
little bit about this my older brother
was also loved acting and
what was it like for thomas i mean i'm
sure i feel like i've talked to him
about this too
yeah but but was that a struggle that
must have been somewhat of a struggle
there couldn't be someone more proud um
of their brother than my brother wasn't
me just the same as when i i remember i
used to think about um when they made
those comparisons you know in the
newspaper connecticut post or whatever
like james maybe it'll be as good as
thomas or maybe and uh remember other
people saying like doesn't that bother
you i'm like no they're comparing me to
my brother i look up to him he's your
hero yeah
it's incredible i want to be compared to
him and then it was like it flipped as
soon as i was getting more of the
attention he couldn't have been more
proud he was the one in the front row i
still remember like people would ask me
like do you hear the crowd when it's
going crazy or whatever and if he's in
the front row i honestly feel like he
was a split second before everyone else
with the cheering and i could hear him i
could hear that he was happy for me and
that genuine happiness that's just you
know he doesn't he did his best in his
career and he wasn't quite the same
level of success but um he was good at
so many other things that i i never
really worried about him but he was just
so happy and proud that i was gonna i
was gonna do well well you probably
probably didn't worry about him because
because he was seemed happy in those
other things he was doing i mean that's
that probably went along yeah
he became friends with all my friends
yeah
traveling he traveled with me some and
it was you guys played together too
right you played doubles together we did
play doubles together a few times on
tour yeah which is awesome it was a ton
of fun and part of the reason i went to
school there was playing doubles with
him and our parents had given so much
for us to play tennis yeah we sacrificed
and spent time and money and effort to
put us through to have us play in tennis
that they got to come watch us together
that's really cool
that's really cool
what um and so you guys when i remember
when we were in high school you had such
a rigorous
i mean i i i to this day i don't think
i've ever seen anything like it i i
never knew anybody who excelled in
sports like that but uh
is that
when you compare uh your
upbringing in the tennis world uh with
other friends viewers who played at that
level it was it typical is that like
what most people who excel like that do
probably it was it was a little
different um which i always talk about
with other tennis players that they
don't need to follow one specific path
it's an individual sport you can do what
works best for you yeah in fact it's
funny to hear you say that because i
felt like i worked really hard in high
school because i was going um i would
show up late for school sometimes
because i was practicing before school
yeah i'd be up at 5 30 practicing when i
could when the court time was free
that's what i remember you constantly
you were like always playing yeah and
getting up and running and then i got to
college and i realized there were people
coming from these tennis academies they
were playing four hours a day five six
hours a day and um i realized that some
of them you know made it some of them
burned out the majority of them burned
out and didn't like tennis anymore so i
was still relatively fresh and that's
why i was kind of new i i still played
high school tennis and getting to that
next level where i was 17 18 19 years
old i still had a lot more improving to
do and i kept working harder and harder
and harder so it was pretty unique i i
mean
of anyone that played pro tennis um at
the level i did there's so few of them
that actually played high school tennis
but they didn't have mr honey as a coach
and you guys like brian rau on the on
the team
that made it so much fun for me to to
play high school tennis but most most
people that played at that level didn't
even bother playing high school tennis
wow okay so it became and i wonder and
do you think that's why most of them a
lot of them burned out i mean is it just
the
yeah
i think about how lucky i am because i i
had my my dad was someone always
preached hard work and wanted me working
harder and harder and harder and um and
i aspired to that i always wanted to do
as much as i could um but i think if i
had been put through what i see at some
of those tennis academies where they're
basically working a pro schedule from
the time they're 10 11 12 years old
um to me that doesn't seem sustainable
to
play for 30 years you know you can play
almost till you're 35 rogers 38 now you
can play until you're 38 years old
possibly on tour you can't start that at
10 and be doing that schedule it's just
not possible on the body
you mentioned somebody like roger
federer when you see him play a a person
like that and you were fourth in the
world at one point you were first in the
us
uh so you've been up there i mean you
know what it's like to compete against
the best
um i remember the game against was it it
was agassi right uh we were all so proud
the whole town was like
everybody was just glued to that um
it was really exciting but now when you
see those players played do you miss it
do you think i could do that still uh
maybe not that level but like i could
still mix it up yes
i feel really really fortunate that i
don't have those kind of regrets i
remember for so long almost every
every couple of press conferences
someone would ask a question like well
what's your goal you know and they're
always looking for that was my next
question
yeah
yeah i want to be 10 in the world i want
to be five in there i want to be one in
the world they're looking for something
concrete right and
i would tell them every time like you
guys answered ask this question i'm
going to give you a boring answer when
i'm done i want to put my rackets down
and have no regrets because i want to do
my best if i do my best and i get
everything i can out of my body then
i've done everything i can even if i
make mistakes along the way i have
losses that i wish i hadn't lost i i
still don't have any regrets asking for
more seems greedy so and i feel like i
accomplished that when i was done i knew
my body was at the point where i
couldn't do it anymore how did that
manifest how did you know
my body just got to a point where i if i
trained hard which i needed to do to
continue the improvement because that's
what i was doing on tour i was one of
the harder workers so i had to i had to
keep working that hard and i got to a
point where if i put in a real hard day
the next day was almost shot it was on
the table getting treatment i was trying
to just get back to neutral and so i
felt like i would go into a tournament
and if i played well in the first round
maybe the second round by the time i got
two matches or three matches into it my
body was just starting to break down so
i felt like towards the end of my career
there's pretty much no way i could go
into a tournament and think i could win
five straight matches because my body
was just what not wasn't allowing me to
do that what is what's the first thing
that would give out like talked talk to
me about the pain
uh
what was that was it your because
another reason my my parents always held
you up to
christian uh you know my brother who you
know um
it was that you both have scoliosis yeah
and christian was like yeah it's about
the only thing we have in common he's
like an amazing athlete i'm not able to
do it but they're like well if james can
do it you know um
but that's hilarious
yeah you really set the bar for him
thanks
uh but you had a brace i mean you had
like quite yeah pretty bad right in high
school yeah which which really didn't
help with being the big man on campus if
you're wearing a back brace from uh
right from armpit down past ladies
wait wait where would it go down james
sorry
all the way into so i had to get uh
different jeans i don't remember i'm
sure you don't remember that but i have
to get wider
big yeah
to go around it yeah so that was uh
that was pretty interesting um but yeah
i had scoliosis but my back was a
problem my shoulder was a problem my
knees became a problem i had surgery on
my knee late in my career and uh that
was a problem but it was all just
it
but but james if you had not to dwell on
the scoliosis but if you hadn't worn
that brace uh god knows what would have
happened right yeah i probably would
have to have surgery i don't know i
don't know what degree christians was
but mine was about 32 degrees okay i
said if it got any worse if it was into
like the high 30s um it's almost
definitely a surgery and the surgery
back then which makes me feel so old um
but when i talk about the surgery back
then they would use leeches
titanium rods put in your back and they
said there's no chance you'd have um
there's no chance you'd be able to play
tennis you wouldn't be able to uh to
twist the way you'd like to and from
what i've heard now the surgeries have
gotten so much better that it's um it's
much more manageable i have no idea if
i'd be able to have the surgery
today and be that functional but um it
makes me feel old to know how far
medicine has advanced you know i know
i know well just yeah put
just bleed it out
yeah a little whiskey yeah cut that one
off it'll grow back you'll be all right
bite on this bullet
and uh
yeah i i remember thinking um i know
we've talked about this and
the embarrassment of wearing
a brace which
to me now seems like the things the
stuff i've been wearing like my
brother's girlfriend's headband this
like very with like a big bow tie on it
and i'm like i i don't have the same
level of discomfort about stuff like
that but in high school
oh my goodness
yeah
it's so different because now yeah now
we're you're comfortable who you are i'm
comfortable with who i am at some point
it doesn't matter i mean i've got two
daughters now they'll they'll be you
know putting stuff on me they'll put
their little bows on me
they'll do whatever and i don't even
think about it i mean i'd say
40 percent of the time i walk out of the
house with like a hair tie on my on my
wrist
because i'm not even thinking about and
i have it and someone calls me out i'm
like oh okay well that's what i got i
got two dollars now this is my life i
don't i don't i'm always glitter there's
glitter on me like
people i must assume i like live in a
strip club or something
nope i swear
yeah how old are they but yeah you don't
think about it now but then yeah i was
so nervous and self-conscious you go in
the gym like you know an athlete i want
to go in a gym class okay i'm gonna you
know show everyone how i thought again
but i was scared because in the locker
room you're changing and i'm taking off
my brace and putting it in a big bag and
then putting it back on and that made me
pretty self-conscious um but especially
you know littler guy you're playing
tennis you're trying to fit in um
it was it was not the easiest thing but
i still
i still feel lucky that i was you know i
had friends like you i had people that
actually liked me just because i was
hopefully a nice to to people and um
having a big brother that was big and
sort of a big man on campus definitely
helped with my credibility because
you know he was he could he could
hopefully beat up anyone that wasn't
that nice to me but well
i would i would say likewise to you
james that like being the little guy and
maybe i'm just saying this because i was
a little guy i think that
perhaps that helped you cultivate a
sense of like a real scrappy personality
and help you cultivate other aspects of
your personality that had you just been
this like big
jock you know who who was really
athletic i don't know i wonder i also
wonder sometimes if it helped your game
you know um developing these skills as a
little player yeah i was just gonna say
that is i actually think about that and
i think you know i always
uh look at things in hindsight and you
think things are bad at the time they
turn out to be good you think things are
good and they turn out to be bad there's
a lot of people that were superstars
when they were 12 or 13 in the tennis
world they kind of don't make it because
they didn't have to
build that skill set they might have
just grown early yeah they were big and
everyone catches up and for me yeah i
had to try to be a complete player
before i grew and then all those skills
were translated to now having more power
more speed and being able to be more
effective so i do think it helps um i'm
still waiting on that personality to
develop for being a little guy and i'm
still you know still working on it you
got time
you're young
uh how old are your daughters by the way
now they are about to be eight and six
eight and six
god so i ran into you now i'm thinking
it was that was two years ago was that
two yeah
yeah in new york god in heaven
crazy yeah the kids are getting all it's
so fun my my oldest daughter just she uh
took it on herself she's such a
self-starter uh it's amazing so during
this like quarantine when we've been
homeschooling she is the easiest to
teach and she just on her own decided to
do some of the extra credit that the
teacher gave and just wrote her book and
i'm
so happy that she did i mean it's like
10 pages and she wrote it herself and
drew the pictures and i'm like this is
incredible she's actually growing up
like she's and you don't judge her you
don't make fun of her teacher's pet
[Laughter]
we're really close to like it's just a
couple years away to me being like as we
talked about when we were starting this
like with us not being great at tech
being like um riley how do you get this
on your phone how do you do and it's
it's close it's already very close oh
they must be yeah because they're
growing up with it they must be so much
yeah better they're doing so much of
their work on these like school um
issued ipads that i'll ask her like how
do you do this and she'll like oh you
want to print it yeah here's how you do
it and i'm like oh my goodness
i had 10 minutes to figure out and she's
got it
and the remote now i mean i feel like an
old man with a remote and like now wait
a minute does this stream do each of
these streams separately
uh
where are you james are you you're not
in fairfield are you san diego yeah oh
san diego that's right yeah yeah so
we've moved out here and i'm very very
lucky we feel pretty lucky that we're a
couple a couple blocks from the beach
and um we got a little you know space
for the kids to play and i love it there
you've been home it's it's great
there were protests and stuff there i
saw it right yeah there have been some
um there have been some
little ones in here because i'm in
solana beach but downtown there were
some big ones um that's like 20 minutes
for me but downtown there's they lit a
building on fire and everything uh some
of the rioters and stuff so that wasn't
great but like up here there have been
some some great like peaceful protests
just groups of 40 50 60 people out with
signs and things like that and um those
have been great how do your daughters
deal with it what is what's their
reaction to it i've always wondered like
how are kids
absorbing what's happening
yeah so my wife and i have been kind of
going back and forth about how much to
explain and how much to talk about with
them because they still haven't seen the
video of me getting attacked in 2015
because i want to be able to really
fully explain it to them before they see
it and my wife and i are now at a point
where we're saying you know what if once
they go back to school their kids now
will have seen that probably and they're
going to talk to them about it so we
need to we need to get ahead of that and
start telling them and explaining so
we're at a point where we're gonna start
talking about it my my eight-year-old i
think will understand will get a lot of
it and she's uh i don't think the
six-year-old is really gonna
um get the the nuance of racism and
everything that's going on um in the in
the country right now but i do think
it's time to start talking to them and
my wife is she has been awesome um in
trying to kind of let me take the lead
on a lot of it um but also she's just
ordered some books and wants to be aware
of like how to teach kids and stuff and
so we're going to do that and we're
going to have to explain to them that
there's there's differences you know
my wife's white and my kids very much
um would not be mistaken for black
they got my wife's pigmentation okay
so it's gonna be interesting to see that
they're not they're hopefully
not gonna experience some of the things
that i experienced uh or my dad
experienced um but they're gonna they're
certainly gonna learn about them and
they're gonna know um their history
they're gonna know their culture um but
they're also hopefully gonna be allies
for anyone that does see uh the effects
of racism and they're gonna
they're gonna hopefully just learn
patience and listening and tolerance and
and everything that we're trying to
teach and
that's what encourages me about a lot of
these protests is how many young people
are out there and
they're gonna be the change that we've
been looking for for the last 40 or 50
years have you seen a moment like this
like i i i mean i i can't remember one
but i'm also not nearly as sensitive to
it as as you would be
yeah so i that's what
um was really
i don't know scary my emotions went so
roller coaster for the last week or so
but the first night when i saw the video
i was so angry so sad um
obviously hurt for the family for uh
anyone that knew george floyd and that
night i went to bed thinking this is
so awful because you know now this is
going to take ahmad arbury out of the
news this is going to take the central
park
news and the sad the thing that really
saddened me is that in two or three days
this might be just right out of the news
and it's gonna be replaced by some
uh dumb comment made by a politician or
something else that happens in the news
that's distracting and then it's gonna
be gone because the 24-hour news cycle
and then waking up the next day and
seeing the protests go on and seeing
that people cared
that encouraged me so much to know that
this country hadn't become totally
desensitized and totally numb when you
see something this egregious that people
are willing to act and i don't believe
without the protests that the officers
would have been charged by now i don't
believe i don't know if they would have
been fired um and
i i it's unfortunate what happened with
the rioting with you know looters kind
of
trying to muddy the message and screwing
it up and white's yelling and that's
antifa the left's young that's white
supremacists and realistically it's
probably some of both but it's just
agitators people that want to create
chaos and and make it so that the
message isn't as clear but it seems like
the message is becoming clear and people
are on board and it's encouraging to get
people asking me
hey what do you think about this people
talking about what they think about it
and
genuinely wanting to learn and that to
me is a younger generation that wants to
be the change
life could be a dream
[Music]
sweetheart the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
pretend i'm your daughter you can do
like a trial run
on
what exactly did happen to you uh in
2015 because i remember
you know reading the headlines like
everybody else and then it was
fascinating talking to you getting your
first hand account of it so i i hope
you're not sick of talking about this
but i would love for you to just walk
everybody through what did happen to you
because it was it could have been a
george floyd situation yeah i was
standing on a corner i was waiting for a
car to take me to the u.s open to do an
appearance this is after
i had retired
so i was just doing some like corporate
appearances i just flown in that morning
i'm waiting for the car
and
i look up and i see someone running
towards me and this is where i first
start thinking how lucky i am because if
i hadn't been
who i am and being in the in new york
during the us open and my first reaction
is
this is a fan um coming to run up to me
and so i'm actually smiling
and my hands are down
and i think about if i had been just a
normal person and i see a big guy
running at me that doesn't say police
doesn't say cop doesn't say hands up
doesn't say anything just running at me
i'm gonna either i'm gonna do one of two
things i'm either gonna swing or i'm
gonna run
and either one of those if i do that i'm
now resisting and there's four other
officers on the scene i'm not just gonna
get taken down i'm gonna get hurt i'm
gonna get possibly killed i'm gonna get
arrested there's gonna be a lot of uh a
lot of serious repercussions to that
um so i feel like i'm lucky that before
i knew it i was on the ground he had
taken me down and he's then he's
starting to pull my hands back and i
i'm still in shock but the first thing i
say because i'd still already seen
plenty of incidents on the news now i'm
assuming this is a police officer
because he's got his knee in my back and
in my back and he's putting my handcuffs
on me i said i'm doing whatever you say
i'm complying 100 whatever you say those
are the first words out of my mouth
because of the conversation i've had i
had with my dad about whenever a cop is
there whenever you do what they say you
comply you handle it later you handle
the legal stuff you handle whatever you
handle any sort of argument you're
having you handle that later sorry to
interrupt james do you remember the
context in which your dad told you that
was is when you you were a kid and he
sits you down
do you remember yeah it was before kind
of around that time when you start like
going out with your friends and you're a
little more independent so probably
around the time i met you okay and you
knew that you were friends with me
yeah it's like this guy's gonna get you
into trouble yeah exactly this kid yeah
89 pound kid he's gonna start getting me
into a lot of trouble
um but yeah it was around then and he
just he explained that the reason my
brother and i had earlier curfews than a
lot of the other kids was that hey if
you're at a party
um and a cop comes in or something
happens or any sort of fight breaks out
you two look different you know we grew
up uh you know we fairfield connecticut
it was our high school was 96 97 percent
white um so
for me he said you and thomas you guys
are going to stand out um and so so if
something goes down you guys might be
the ones that get into big trouble and
so he's like i don't want to do that i
want to protect you and just so you know
like if something does happen you guys
are not fighting you're not belligerent
you're saying whatever and then we'll
handle it from there you know if i get
in trouble because of something i did
with the you know because the police got
me in trouble and i'm worried that like
my dad's gonna catch me whatever he was
like look that's not what we're worried
about we want you know i want to keep
you safe so so because of that i you
know i said i'm 100 complying wait sorry
james i sorry to i i want to get back to
it but but this is interesting to me
when you were
that age how aware were you in the
differences between
white and black people were was it
something that you were aware of being
outnumbered by people did you have that
feeling
definitely um and it was it was
interesting because i felt like i went
between
two worlds which i think is it may be
common when you're talking about a
mixed-race person so um i was in
fairfield high school that was i said 95
96 percent white whatever it was and
then i would go down to harlem uh to
play tennis every sunday and that was
one white yeah exactly 98 99 black or
latino and but a minority community and
so i would go there and
again like with the trying to fit in
this is a time in your life when you're
self-conscious so you're trying to fit
in so you're in the black community on
one day and then you're in the white
community on a greater part of your your
life and
you don't want to be
um you don't want to stand out so if you
go to the black community and they're
afraid you're not you know you hear this
a lot he's like oh well is he black
enough and then you go to the white
community like well you're black so
you're an outsider and it's it's always
trying to fit in and that's i think
it's not unique to any high school kid
because they're trying to fit in with a
certain clique or a certain group or
whatever but
for me it was definitely it made me very
aware that i'm going between two totally
different worlds and
i'm trying and trying to fit into both i
need to it may have again trying to be
think about positive and optimism trying
to think about the fact that i was lucky
it may have helped me be aware of who i
was independent of having to be a part
of one world that makes sense
so i tried to think about you know what
what makes me happiest uh in these
situations i can still
laugh at the jokes there i can still
laugh at the jokes here on both sides
and i still understand them both and i
don't have to and it got me to a point
where i don't have to commit to being
just like everyone in each group and
that helped me to grow up i think and it
took i mean it sounds like that happened
overnight but it didn't that was a long
time i'm sure yeah so because in high
school it's confusing enough as it is i
mean i just think for
just being any kid uh and and trying to
figure out who you are and your
personality and
did you find yourself behaving like
altering your behavior or the way you
talked or the things you joked about
between different groups between white
and black groups
yeah definitely because i mean the
things i would talk about
in fairfield high school or fairfield
woods and middle school or whatever
we're definitely different than when i
go down to harlem
so if i was talking about you know um
you know
i don't know um
some of the things that were going on i
mean i feel like when we were in high
school you're
i don't know like just the clothes
you're wearing you go you got your j
crew outfit you got your
everyone had their whatever the nice ll
bean backpack and everything and then
you go into uh harlem and no one's even
heard of any of those those clothes or
any of those things and it's totally
different it's like a different um
different attire different everything
and it's just different different things
that you're talking about so yeah i
wouldn't be able to talk about the same
things yeah when you talk to your
daughters about this how are you going
to
because they haven't had the experience
that you had of feeling
different of looking different you said
they used to they they're gonna if they
fit in with in like a white
world how are you gonna describe how it
felt and like i'm asking i guess for you
to describe it to me too because i'm
trying to understand how i i know i'll
never understand fully but how would you
describe it that feeling well i just
want to let them know that this is what
they need to think about is that you
know you're they're so close to their
dad that
there were plenty of people in this
world that made me feel not good just
because of the way i look
and explaining it to them i would try to
explain you would never want anyone to
make you feel different or out of place
for something that's the way you were
born and
whether it be because you have blonde
hair or dark hair or
you're tall or short or anything like
that it's just the way you were born so
i would try to explain to them that too
often people can make others feel bad
about that and that's something i never
want them to do so just explain to them
that they're they may not have the same
feelings that i had they may never
experience that
but just so they know i want to explain
to them how much that can hurt someone
and that even if it seems like their
friends are doing it and someone's like
someone's just joking and someone's
playing tough because if someone joked
with me in high school i would
with the same thing with what we've been
talking about i would try to fit in i
would try to laugh it off what form
would that take james do you remember
any instances and you obviously don't
you know to say names or anything but do
you remember what that sounded like i
mean i remember one
one incident of as i said it was very
much a white community and
um one of the guys that uh at one of the
parties had said
he had i think it was like he had gotten
into a skiing accident his face was kind
of you know it looked like he had
scratched up and beat up and he said
something
to his friends and he said the n-word he
said a bunch of you know bunch of ends
jumped me as as a joke
and
i just thought i just looked and i i
looked right at him and then he looked
at me as
oh but i didn't you know you know i
didn't mean you or whatever i was like
well you did like as much as you didn't
like you didn't know i was here i was
right behind you and i you had forgotten
that there actually was a black kid that
goes to high school with you and is
right there and it's like those kind of
things and
what is that fee and sorry not to get to
oprah but like what does that feel like
for a kid for you at the time so that to
me was that was
one of the first times where i where i
really did want to stand up and i was
still little at the time i think i was
probably a sophomore in high school and
i wanted to stand up but it was a bigger
kid he was i think a junior or senior
and
um i can't really stand up and
physically fight him and i don't think
that would help in any way i just i wish
i had stood up a little more because i
just kind of let him know it was wrong
and then he just you know kind of went
about his business and and sort of went
to the other side of the room and but i
wish i had been a little more vocal
about saying hey come here let's just
let's just talk about how
how you're thinking and how you think
that's okay because if that was a
mistake which i'm sure it was you're 16
years old 17 years old or whatever like
let's talk about how that thought
process can change i wish i'd been a
little more proactive instead of just
calling him out and then moving on but
again you're at age you don't think as
much about that and you don't have the
same kind of confidence that i would
have today i heard that so it just made
me feel like i can't believe these
people when i'm not around may say a lot
of these things
that they you know that they're uh they
watch what they say around you yeah
they're censoring around me and you know
i was right behind him so he didn't know
i was there and i wonder how often he
said that when i wasn't around and it
made me think a lot about that
yeah i bet i'll never have that
experience but i guess like what did it
mean to you
to be not made fun of but to be
belittled
for
that i mean like
being surrounded by so many white people
what did black culture mean to you when
you were in high school
what did what was that hurting that word
i didn't feel like there was the
curiosity back then that there is now
which is which again is encouraging
because i think people would just
see me and
almost assume because i played tennis
because i was doing well in school that
they could talk to me and
we all have the same experiences and
i've heard that so many times as as i've
gotten older that oh you went to a white
high school and so you don't know black
culture like just because you went to a
white house a high school doesn't mean
you can't read a book you can't know
about culture you can't learn and you
can't then still experience because um
yeah there's
systemic racism that's
inherent in our entire country with the
police system with the mass
incarceration with so many things like
that that we're all
uh that are present for all of us but
it's not like it's isolated because you
go to a white high school that means
you're not going to see racism
you may see it more so you may see yeah
maybe different just different forms
yeah you're you're completely standing
out as opposed to if you go to a
predominantly black high school where
you feel like the majority and maybe you
feel like you fit in so much more and
so i definitely
i definitely feel like when i went to
high school when i was around so many
white people i just didn't feel like
they
thought there was much difference and
that was when i had my instant 2015 it
was actually interesting because i do
think a lot of people were
their eyes were open even people that i
told because the the video wasn't
available for three days so i had told a
lot of my friends it was on the news
that this happened but there wasn't that
video and the video i think for a lot of
people made it real and so some of the
guys i played on on tour with uh one of
them called me after the video came out
and he was like i i almost can't watch
that he's like it made me sick to see
what they did to you and i was like i
told you what happened two days ago and
he's like yeah but it's just he's like
i've never known anyone like that where
that could happen to them and it's you
like it just doesn't seem like that
could happen to you
like i was i was in this world of pro
tennis and were somewhat isolated it's
mostly white um a lot of it affluent and
you just didn't think like this kind of
stuff happened you're protected
yeah and it's just like you know what if
you take me out of that system i'm still
the same guy that um when i'm walking
down the street if not a tennis fan they
don't know me they see me as just a
black man that's it that's nothing else
and that unfortunately sometimes is just
seen as a suspect
and you know i i'm aware of that i've
been aware of that for all the times i
got pulled over in high school when i
was driving my mom's car all the times i
finally you know i had some i made some
money and i have a nice car and i'm
driving around in a nice car and i'm a
young black man um with dreads you know
i'm getting pulled over pretty much
every time i drive out of my driveway so
that happened in high school
what's up that happened a lot in high
school
yeah in high school it was funny my mom
used to say because um i mean my brother
and i had shared a beat up old piece of
junk car and then
um my mom if we had to take my mom's car
somewhere which wasn't exactly like a it
wasn't a benz or anything but it was at
least not it was i think it was an acura
that was
it was okay and if either one of us
drove that it was amazing she said she
could drive with um expired plates or
expired tags for six months a year but
the second one of us got in it we'd go
walk out and we get a ticket i bet your
parents they must have experienced uh
their fair share
of
racism and of people
again in in a white town they're a mixed
race couple uh yeah you do you remember
what were your first impressions um of
that as as a kid do you remember do you
remember like the first time you noticed
oh they're being treated differently
yeah so my dad uh kept a lot of that to
himself but my mom later told us about
incidents that happened because they
were i mean they were married in the 70s
and you know so mixed-race couple in the
70s um
my dad was very aware of it my mom was
probably naive before she met him and
couldn't believe all the
um sort of hoopla or ruckus around it
because they you know she was just in
love with him so it didn't matter and
she could never care she never cared she
come from an open-minded like a very
progressive like a tolerant family
um her mom yes her dad died when she was
very young but her mom yes was very
accepting and very happy um
with um my dad because he treated her
and it had nothing to do with the colors
he treated her right he was respectable
he loved her her first husband was white
and he was
not a very nice person and did not treat
her very well so her parent her mom was
extremely happy just to have someone
treating her right so
they were very open and accepting
um and she had two kids from her first
marriage and they were also very open
and accepting and um they're awesome um
still close especially to the younger
one
now and they're they were so great and
they you know when my dad passed they
were both there for the funeral they
were both um pretty broken up about it
um so
they're um yeah the family was great and
they experienced tons of stuff but i
remember i remember feeling
different when those natural questions
started coming up in school with your
with your friends like well how come
you know i get a tan and you're you kind
of always have a tanner how come your
hair is different and it's which is
great and that's i think how we're going
to start with my kids is like those
genuine questions like yeah your hair is
curly so much and mine is straight and
so that's when i would go home and ask
my parents those questions and that's
how the
those conversations kind of started and
um i still remember like the first time
me like explaining to i want to say a
first grader or a second grader like
well i'm half black and half white like
so do you mean like it's cut down the
middle like your right is black and
you're left and like i think about those
questions now how innocent they were and
how awesome
like kids want to just know and
that's when it needs to be taught and
that's where hopefully
all these young people now are teaching
the kids
the positive ways to learn about that
instead of so many that are teaching
them this indoctrinated theory of white
being superior and black being inferior
and um right um hopefully many of those
days have passed i mean sadly
it's too prevalent still in this country
but i really hope it's waning well james
that's what i've been thinking about in
terms of you know the social media push
that everyone's doing which is great to
see it's great to see such a that people
are taking time away from promoting
themselves or whatever to really focus
on on this and so people are sharing a
lot of useful information and
the thing and this happened on
my instagram and i and i've heard i've
seen it written so many times in in
different forms but uh the
it's the at the heart of it is that when
they'll say
all lives matter why why just black
lives and
well i'm curious how you would respond
to that um
and and because i have
you know i'm wondering i've seen
different responses to it and i've i i
have my own feelings but i'm more
curious about what you would say to that
so actually it's funny um as i mentioned
my wife's white she posted something
explaining on her instagram why all the
all lives matter um
can be seen as racist and it's just
demeaning um because all lives matter
we know that everyone knows that all
lives matter like there
are laws that protect all lives those
laws have been flaunted when it comes to
black lives you know black lives are the
ones that have been taken for granted
they've been treated as second class
citizens their lives are taken for
granted there's no justice for when they
are
killed injured incarcerated um so it
needs to be um it needs to be proven it
needs to be said that black lives matter
it doesn't need to be said that all
lives matter because
we all have accepted that we've all yeah
created laws we've done these things
it's one of the commandments i mean
moses was told that exactly
we don't need to say that and that's
where it makes it um demeaning to take
away from you're trying to take away
from the fact that the black lives
matter like look we've proven that white
lives matter because there is justice
when a white person gets killed when a
black man gets killed at the hands of a
cop
for so long i mean you see the lists of
names and no justice for them so we have
to say something we have to stand up and
we have to say look black lives matter i
know that all lives matter but we've all
we've all addressed that all lives
matter well we've all agreed on that
in my grandmother's lifetime in my dad's
lifetime emmett till i was reading about
emmett till and yeah the lynching of
emmett till in 1955. he he would be
younger than my dad right now um and i
was thinking we were talking about going
to school together i i i don't remember
learning about any of this
no in school for one thing why isn't
anti-racism taught in school
um that that should be taught at a young
age with these kids so they can they can
learn it early um and the other thing is
yeah black history isn't isn't taught
and my response to that is my guess
is that it's very difficult to change a
public school curriculum and if you try
to and if you try to put in any sort of
black history
there is going to be
uproars of people that um are the
you know older generation that say nope
you're not going to
go away from teaching this christopher
columbus and the
european history and
revising it how we wanted and we want it
to be and we started this country around
a table that was very cordial and we
definitely didn't just slaughter the
native americans we you know it was all
peaceful we sat down together for
thanksgiving and it was friendly and
yeah this is how the whole country
started like that's the story made it
equal no that's not exactly how it
started let's start teaching some of the
actual the actual facts behind it
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
you were talking about uh i want to go
back to the incident as you call it in
2015. so he's got his knee in your back
which now to everyone hearing this is
probably has some chilling connotations
um yeah he's kneeling on you
um and what happens next
so then he picks me up and at this point
i assume he is a police officer because
he's got me cuffed and he walks me over
and then the first sign i have for sure
is that the people he walks me over to
they have badges on their um on their
belt so they're all still plain clothes
um and
they're asking me what i'm doing and i
tell them look i i assume you guys made
a mistake like i've done nothing i'm
just here waiting for a car to take me
to the us open my badge is in my back
pocket for the us open you can take that
you can see
and they just look for my my actual id
they take it
and then he's just not listening to me
they're not listening at all to me
saying like look i'm going to just open
i have nothing to do with whatever
you're looking for eventually they tell
me well we're looking for someone that's
been we got we have a witness that told
us you've been collecting
stuff from a credit card you've been
ordering things from a credit card and
uh they've been delivered here to the
hyatt uh for the last two weeks i said
two weeks i'm like perfect let's go up
to my hotel room i have my uh flight
ticket i just landed uh like six hours
ago like i have my my flight itinerary
come let's go let's go look at it and
settle this and we're done
okay yeah we'll we'll see we'll see
about that okay okay are they being
aggressive how are they speaking to you
so they were pretty short and not um and
the only thing was uh the one time one
of them said like you know you're safe
right and i actually responded honestly
i said no i don't um you know because
i'm extremely vulnerable i've never been
handcuffed like that before i'm
handcuffed standing in front of uh in
front of a tournament hotel where i'm
sure people know who i am and i'm like
i'm not i don't know that like oh well
you are i was like well i'm handcuffed
here i'm not and then i even asked i was
like do you mind um if because we were
in the middle of the sidewalk i said do
you mind if we at least go over to like
a better area like a more secluded area
and they just looked at each other and i
said no
and we're gonna stay here and i was like
okay i mean what can i say and this is
where i was i wanted to be so vocal i
wanted to scream i wanted to be the one
saying you guys are making a mistake
yelling at them but i just i know that's
never going to accomplish anything so i
tried to be as polite as possible and
every time to say look you guys made a
mistake this is i'm not the person
you're looking for i don't know who it
is you're looking for but i am not that
person eventually it took about 10
minutes 10 to 12 minutes or so when the
one of the police officers looked and he
was looking at his phone and they looked
at me looking at his phone looked at me
and he said to the officer that i
actually talked to him he's like i think
we may we may have made a mistake here
and he finally like so he lets me go and
there's no apology nothing the the
officer
the closest came to an apology was he's
walking with me and he said
uh well just so you know the person
we're looking for is still in the area
i don't really care like that has
nothing to do with me that's yeah so
watch your credit cards yeah
yeah i had nothing to do with that so i
was just kind of still in shock at that
point and left and
what i hadn't considered when i heard
about it uh until you told me about it
is the embarrassment too of like yeah
that happening in front of your
colleagues in front of you yeah i was i
mean i'm handcuffed for 10 15 minutes
outside a hotel where um a bunch of you
guys open players and junior players and
stuff stay and
um and fans i'm sure and so i'm standing
there and definitely embarrassed but
more i was more focused on being so
vulnerable because yeah obviously i have
no control these guys can do whatever
they want to be i'm handcuffed and uh
and so that was the the scary situation
and yeah then there's there was no
remorse from them nothing at all as if
they'd done anything wrong and
um that's that's where it gets so
frustrating is that then
i decided to talk to the press a little
bit later it was my wife that kind of
convinced me to actually because i
called her and you know being the
athlete i want to say oh i'm going to
brush you know i'm going to
go past this i can deal with it i'm fine
i'm not you know it's not my you know
i'm gonna just tough it out yeah and um
she said no i mean how can you how can
you even imagine if that happened to
someone else someone that you cared
about me anyone else you can't you can't
be quiet so i was like oh you're right
as soon as she said like what if this
happened to me or what's happening with
someone else i was like absolutely right
sorry somebody who looks up to you you
know a lot of kids looked up to you so i
so i went to the press and
eventually when i after i went to the
press i realized that it's been hours
they had no idea that i had gone to the
press they had no idea of anything like
that
um so
they hadn't filed any report and
they hadn't done anything and then when
it goes to the press then the
commissioner comes out and says well
we're looking into if there was any any
abuse we're looking into we don't think
he was even in cuffs or if he was it was
for less than a minute
and they don't know there's a video out
there i didn't know there was a video
out there and i'm just fuming i'm going
i can't believe they're going to refute
this story and they're going to be five
officers that say nothing happened
and i'm going to be the one that's
that's saying this and they're going to
they're going to make it that i'm the
one that's uh not to be believed yeah
from the power that from the like
highest echelon of of of authority from
the commissioner yeah the commissioner
says and i mean i
i don't know where to place all the
blame but he may have heard the story
from them so their story is nothing
happened and he said he has to come out
and say well you know this guy's making
this up and i mean what kind of cop
would just tackle a guy for no reason a
non-violent crime and he wasn't doing
anything wrong he's gonna he's gonna say
he really stood there with his hands
down and was smiling at this guy no one
would do that
and so it did sound unbelievable and
that's the way i told my friends that's
the way i told the story and then lo and
behold there's a video and it shows that
everything i said was true and now then
they have to backtrack they have to say
oh no you know okay well now we're still
looking into it and we're you know we're
we're going to assess it and we're
that's when they apologized
but they still they spun it how they
wanted to they
they waited until september 11th the
release of it they wouldn't let us
release the video
because we we officially didn't have
control of it the complete the police
did and so we had we were going to have
to subpoena them to get the footage and
they
released it on their own on september
11th the morning of september 11th
obviously knowing that you can't say
anything bad about a cop in new york on
on september 11th wow
they i mean it's it's pretty amazing to
think like their
the the police departments have pretty
big political spin doctors as well
what what was the net result what ended
up happening what was so the net result
was after two years of them
having uh these internal uh proceedings
where i told them i want to be at them
i'm going to be in the courtroom i want
to be there i say my piece at the trial
it's up to one independent judge or a
judge that is in the police force that
then is it goes to the commissioner to
have the final say but they dock him
five vacation days and that was it and i
i reserved the i withdrew my right or i
uh for for went my right to sue them
um for them starting a fellowship
for three years uh someone that's funded
by the uh by the city of new york
in their budget full pay and and
benefits to handle cases like this
because they're overloaded i mean i had
my own lawyer which is great but most
people don't have that so this is
someone a fellow that's on staff to
handle pieces of police brutality the
kicker is that then he also sued me for
defamation
what yeah he tried to sue me um it was
thrown out but my lawyer when he heard
that he couldn't believe he said oh my
god please let please let the judge not
throw it out and let's get him on trial
we we got him
um and
he said i can't wait to get him under
oath but uh defamation for what
defamation for saying that what happened
yeah he sued so he sued he sued me he
sued my book publisher he sued um the
city of new york he sued the nypd
um and he sued the civilian complaint
review board the board that um that
charged him so he sued all of us i
shouldn't say he sued i just said he
tried to sue all of us wow
uh james i could talk to you for hours
do you mind just doing a quick lightning
round this is frivolous this uh to get a
little light even i know it's hard to be
light now but okay um well
you just use all the guests this is the
uh our lightning round okay all right
what is
i don't know how to pivot from
systemic racism uh to this but here we
go what is your most commonly used emoji
i don't i don't use them emojis
my friends know that i do not use emojis
never yeah no i'm against them
what really why why i don't know i just
since the start i'm like these things
are ridiculous why am i going to do this
and since then as i don't know if you
remember from high school i'm pretty
stubborn and then i just stuck to it i
don't i don't use the emojis
okay okay
you'll be our first uh non-emoji user
not even like a parent uh like a colon
and a
no i'm i'm big i'm a ha ha i don't even
do lol
all right we'll do haha when we because
when your episode comes out we like to
emoji okay uh it is people are going to
think it might be part of your name like
oh he dropped a haha like haha clinton
dicks
from his name
uh okay well our second question again
these are all formulas this is what we
do with everyone
so i'm gonna ask you if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why
uh i would love to be a golfer uh oh
yeah you like golf yeah i love golf but
also i mean you uh you get to play
beautiful courses you're
uh
you're not as stressed physically and
you can do it for pretty much your whole
life senior senior tour goes for until
you're 60 or so if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be oh chips and salsa oh
yeah oh love it i've eaten so much of
that in quarantine oh yeah any any
particular brand they'll send you free
stuff uh el napolito it's a local brand
here i eat it non-stop it's so good nice
this is one that people shame me for
what's your favorite movie of all time
favorite movie yeah or like top three if
you can't just do one uh i'll do one
good will hunting love that oh the
harvard connection a little bit i love
that and i just thought that was such a
cool story that one and i mean there two
they're very similar is that one and i
love finding forrester oh yeah they are
kind of similar yeah and right around
the same time yeah so those are those
are the two that if they're on while i'm
you know while i'm up at night or can't
sleep i gotta watch the whole thing and
i think both gus van sant right
uh i didn't know uh i didn't know
finding forester was as well i was that
sean connery it's john connor yeah yeah
yeah rob brown yeah that's the one where
he goes i remember the trailer he goes
punch the couch
yeah
you're the man now dog
right
excellent connery very very impressive i
can only do those two lines um
uh if you had to live somewhere else
besides san diego where would it be
oh fairfield i'd go back i'd go right
back fairfield yeah i loved it there uh
friends and stuff are still there and if
if it wasn't for the weather i think we
would have stayed do you come back to
visit because your mom still lives here
i do i come back we usually come back
every summer this time you know because
of kovid we're not coming back this
summer but every summer we come back for
about two or three weeks usually and see
my mom
uh okay who uh sorry almost done uh
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met who who would they be arthur ashe
uh-huh usually if i'm asked three people
i wanna have dinner with my dad's always
on there i mean jackie robinson probably
just because he was such a trailblazer
as well that's a really good three yeah
that'd be that'd be a great that'd be a
great dinner party yeah yeah what was
your dad's favorite food favorite meal
uh my dad's favorite meal i mean he was
it's gonna sound really boring but salad
twice a week my mom made him a huge
salad and one of those big it wasn't
even like a normal but it was like a
mixing bowl big mixing bowl
oh a big salad like a big salad like
yeah he used to have the big salad twice
a week for dinner and that was the only
way his favorite that and uh
i mean that's obviously so healthy but
his one i'd say weakness or
uh
was the cheesecake having baked salad
and then cheesecake
balance it yeah um
if you could have one superpower what
would it be
oh um
i'd say maybe being invisible being able
to know uh kind of what's going on when
you're not around that'd be cool um yeah
uh who's your favorite muppet
hard-hitting i know
my favorite muppet um
i liked the uh the swedish guys
who should be
i love that james just did this with his
hands like he just uh he's grabbing
something uh no but i love his hands
yeah well i love that it had he had such
human i mean he did have human hands uh
if you could be one age for the rest of
your life what would you pick physically
uh
24
yeah ah
i missed 24. yeah i mean i've had
nothing nothing went wrong at 22.
i mean you get a
you get a knee injury it's done in a day
you you have a you have a few too many
on a night and you're you're okay oh
yeah yeah i'm crappy at 9 00 a.m at 10
a.m you're fine
yeah
you're like a superhero you're like i'm
trying to think somebody who just like
regenerates you can almost see the
wounds
feeling in front of you yeah
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick
oh a non-human um
i think
dogs get treated pretty well yeah you
could be a dog and you're i mean you got
your owner picking up after you and
pretty much taking you to the groomers
and all that kind of stuff they got a
pretty good life yeah it'd be a little
shameful i guess uh [ __ ] in front of
people but
but
i mean is it more shameful to do that in
front of people or to have them cleaning
it up or being in the world or cleaning
it up like oh no you're good over there
let me just grab them let me just grab
this bag it's not that bad it's fine
that's true throughout our whole walk
yeah they don't seem to care yeah
um
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny
um unattractive yeah um which golden
girl do you most identify with dorothy
blanche rose or so oh believe me i've
already been made fun of by my wife for
knowing uh dorothy blanche rose um uh
and sophia and knowing um their real
names rue mcclanahan uh
bea arthur
betty white um and estelle getty why did
she make fun of you that's cool yeah she
thinks i'm a nerd for knowing all right
but uh well she would think i'm the
biggest nerd for asking
i think i i
most
uh relate to probably the b arthur
character dorothy just kind of the smart
ass and uh
yeah yeah uh pragmatic i guess that's
why we're friends because we know that
uh
well
that's our generation
uh what which do you prefer dogs or cats
dogs uh-huh do you have a dog i don't
and i'm holding off my kids keep asking
me and i just i've got two kids and like
it's enough physically to deal with that
that i haven't been picking up their poo
it's just it's i told them they got to
wait two years two years and then we got
we're getting a dog you're hoping
they're they'll forget like that's a
long time they're never going to forget
and because she's already assumed that
it's on her 10th birthday she's allowed
to get a dog
she's already got it penciled in okay
okay
uh the beatles or the rolling stones uh
beetles
okay yep right answer and um
uh do you ever think james about like
how you want to be remembered as a
tennis player or in the tennis world do
you ever think about like how you want
people to remember you and in your yeah
i remember thinking about during my
careers i wanted to be remembered as
someone that just did things the right
way um you know i just i competed hard i
wanted to win um i tip my cap to those
that beat me um and i
uh the ones that i that i beat i i
respected them and knew that they were
trying their hardest as well so i just
wanted to be remembered as being a good
competitor
well
i'm pretty sure you'll be remembered
that way and i think you'll also be
remembered as somebody who
really lived their values and uh and and
lived it for other people to to see as
an example like a really really noble
example of how to be um that's how i
think of you uh thank you justin i
appreciate that
okay thanks buddy stay safe and uh yeah
best of the family thanks a lot you too
justin
[Music]
so
that happened
that's your high school james yeah yeah
it's like that's i can when i think of
james sometimes i still think of him as
as a guy like hey hey guys are you guys
you going to party i should clarify that
the reason we didn't we were slightly
annoyed by constantly giving rides to
james was
because nobody wanted to be the one to
drive in high school you didn't want to
do certain things while you and then
drive right um we didn't have uber back
then it was before ride sharing we
called it designated driver yes
but also speaking of driving he talks
about his mom having the nice car yeah i
remember that i was surprised to hear
that he had he got pulled over a lot and
he got tickets a lot and his mom they
had a running joke in their family where
he and his brother the second they drove
the nice car something would happen and
their mother their white mother
could get away with anything for six
months yeah plates and
i know and that's one of those i mean
we're talking this week about our own
role in or how we can be better and
improve society and and
lend our voices to the what's going on
and and uh
you know that's an example of something
that i just hadn't i had been ignorant
of we're not racist people but i think
we've been complicit in
certain
racist adjacent ways of thinking which
is
or just not thinking you know not being
aware of some
yeah of course well we both grew up in
like we've said fairfield connecticut
shout out which is
a very white town and that's not to say
it's a very racist town but
it's a town that prevents you from
having to address any sort of racial
issues so it was like growing up in a
bubble it i it just never really
occurred to me
that that type of thing could happen
here but hearing from him it of course
it makes sense that he was a black kid
in this white town in a system that is
and he had issues with the cops even in
this town and it's the fact that i'm
still surprised to hear something like
that yeah
has to change you know what i mean like
that's part of changing exactly me
acknowledging that it's more of a
problem than it is i know then i
realized i would i was surprised to
learn that he had a curfew not because
we i always thought i assumed when we
were kids when we were in high school
that it was because he had to get up to
play tennis because james was
in my estimation like
obsessive which you have to be to be at
that level about playing tennis um and
so we i that's just what i assumed oh
he's got to be up early like the father
wants him home
and come to find out it was the father's
concerns about totally justified
concerns that they might get blamed
and concerns that not only are totally
valid considering what ended up
happening to him in his life
but concerns that i can't even begin to
relate to well that's the thing like i
just never thought about his blackness
but i never considered what it meant
to be to have that skin color and live
in
live in his shoes i know well yeah it
struck me when he was recounting the
story of the cop tackling him and he and
he said
you know i was a known
person i was celebrated people people
recognized me often especially then yeah
around the us open in new york and he
did a lot of james had a lot of
contracts because he's a handsome guy he
sure he was he was a very well-known
person yeah the cop didn't
wasn't a fan of tennis so
since he wasn't a fan of tennis james
just became
a black guy
you know what i mean so it it's like he
could be
he could which he did he he could be a
wealthy famous accomplished athlete uh
gone to harvard done all these great
charitable things
but if you don't know who he is
then he's a black guy to someone yeah
and yeah the fact that he was reduced to
that yeah the fact exactly the fact that
james blake who is as accomplished as a
person can get
regardless of skin color
um can be reduced to
a black guy who is who can then be
reduced naturally in a lot of people's
eyes to a suspect
is really um really really really sad
it's upsetting and i um
james mentioned this but i was thinking
about thinking about brianna taylor
because uh people have been first the
conversation centered around ahmad aubry
and then george floyd and now i think
people are are
recognizing the the
tragedy that of brianna taylor and the
fact that she was
just sounded like such a wonderful
person um by all accounts i've just been
reading about her and and
james mentioned her it really
personalized it for me in the way that
i'm sure it's been personalized for
every black person whenever they see
something or hear about something like
this happening
um i thought about my friend james
had he not put his hands down had he
been more defensive or reacted naturally
uh to that cop charging him had he not
thought he was a fan exactly you know
you think about what could have happened
and this has become
over the last he got lucky you know yeah
over the last week or so this has become
a very polarizing political issue and i
i i just don't think it should be
it shouldn't be a political issue it it
shouldn't be the black lives matter
people versus the all lives matter
people because in part
the all lives
matter discrepancy is
in my opinion just a complete mis
communication of what the message is
there it's not
only black lives matter it's right black
lives matter also yeah so yeah i mean
you guys talk about that in the
interview james says that he said you
know it's not about it people already
know that the white lives matter right
the issue is the black lives exactly it
doesn't need to be said michael che has
a great stand up about that and he says
we're asking for the bare minimum that
they matter and the only reason it needs
to be said is because of the the history
of them not mattering that continues
today and and the system that has been
put in place it's to me it's such
basic logic it's so easy and and all you
need to do is is take a cursory glance
at our history and and black history of
oppression in this country the reason
people are
it's become polarizing in part is
because there's been such an
overwhelming influx of
social media outpouring and posts and
people and i think
i think to the other side quote unquote
they feel like they're being bombarded
with this kind of virtue signaling stuff
and
but the truth is
this is not a new issue right this is
not like oh in the last two weeks racism
has become a problem right racism has
been a problem since the beginning well
our country was built on the backs of
slaves yeah so
we never learned this stuff i talked to
james about that too yeah this is all
i've been the last week i've also been
wanting to educate myself and i've been
i posted about some of the podcasts i've
been listening to and the history i've
been consuming but you talk about like a
significant person being reduced to
their skin color that story is that
continues has continued throughout
history and and they're far more grisly
examples of it like i read about this
guy anthony crawford who
owned a ton of land he was a very
impressive person
uh strong person and uh gave all these
this acreage to his family and
and he stood up to a white store owner
and was
lynched by the town i mean
and this happened
and then you look at the dates where
these things are happening
emmett till happened in 1955 emmett till
was killed at 14. emmett hill would be
younger than our dad right now
crawford was killed in 1990 he was
killed within grandma's lifetime like
this it's not like we're so far removed
from these
uh horrific tragedies and and now we're
like
they're literally happening today right
i mean i think it is fair it's accurate
to say we have come a long way since the
days of slavery and jim crow and civil
rights but i think it's also accurate to
say that we have a very long way to go
and
um
you guys talked about the need for
education and the need for
certain people who have certain belief
systems dying out because
like he pointed out
and he's experienced this with people
firsthand there are some people who just
will not be shaken in terms of their
beliefs so uh i think the key like you
said like you were both talking about is
education and and i think i mean what
the hell do i know but i think that
there should be more
uh awareness of black history from a
very early age and empathy for black
totally i remember very loosely learning
about you know frederick douglass
yeah a little bit even that nat turner
was was i remember
he was painted as a
um
a revolutionary but not like more of
like a rebel more of like a rogue
revolution right instead of like a hero
right and you learn about separate equal
and civil rights act and you you have
sort of a
cursory knowledge of a lot of these
things but let's face it by and large
our history growing up was european
history and
i think it's time that that changes i do
too and it's by the way it's just not
accurate either he talked about having
scoliosis oh yeah and
i
also have scoliosis like you said
um and i remember i compared you guys
before i had ever met him he i remember
getting my diagnosis and i was very
scared and insecure and i was um you
know i was faced with the
potential of having the surgery that he
talked about those titanium rods and
instead i got a second opinion and we
opted for what he also went through
which is wearing a back brace a full
body back brace and i was very
uncomfortable and i was
you know insecure about it i was at that
age
yeah that we talked about in the
beginning everyone's insecure to some
extent then and i had even more of a
reason to be insecure because my back
was crooked and i didn't want people to
notice and um and
you told him
that uh that i was going through this
which was
very nice of you and
he called me i never met him and he
called me on the phone
and i had only heard of him at this
point he was a big high school star he
was a big tennis star and he i don't
remember exactly what he said to me but
it was something to the effect of
uh it's gonna be okay it's not that bad
you'll get through it it was just
encouraging and i forgot about that and
i was i was so like
touched by that yeah
yeah
yeah
uh
sorry no
no then you think about uh
you you think about what you can boil
this whole thing down to uh
what do we do why aren't we uh
able to see the kindness in one another
he the humanity in one another uh
i know for someone who's like i
considered a lot of people consider to
be
heroic in some way i mean he at the end
he said he he'd want to have dinner with
jackie robinson and arthur ashe and but
there's a lot of young black kids i i
i assure you out there who see james
blake as arthur ashe yeah and see him as
jackie robinson and yeah and and for
time i i saw him that way i he helped me
out and he did a very kind thing for me
but
she was as a tennis player there was
something heroic about him and and to
imagine
him
getting tackled just because of the
color of his skin it's
it it like hurts me yeah
yeah
it's
uh yeah it's horrible i
so i just you know i wonder if this is
um
in terms of
understanding what it's like
uh
again i mean
something will never truly be able to
but um
i wonder how
close it is to that feeling of of uh
the i mean imagine how the injustice you
would feel if a friend if your friend if
a friend of yours now imagine if like uh
it it happened to a family member if
you're brianna taylor's
you know mother uh well i can't imagine
yeah
um
and through it all
he's such a
optimistic person still yeah yeah do you
notice that every time
there was something
bad being talked about he found a way to
put a positive spin on it which was
god
like i don't i don't think i could do
that no you know
he's encouraged by the protests he's
he uh he's obviously upset that what
happened to him wasn't dealt with with
the proper amount of justice that the
guy who did that to him is not only
still on the force but lost five
vacation days after having five
incidents crazy racially motivated
instance before that it's it's
unacceptable it's um it's something that
should outrage uh everyone it's some it
it should not be a divisive issue that
what happened to james
uh forget the killing of george floyd
and brianna what happened to james
that just that should outrage everyone
because everyone is policed
by by the police everyone depends on the
police to protect and serve
and if that happened to anybody's friend
family member if that happened to
anybody they'd be outraged so everyone
should be that we should be collectively
outraged yes i agree
um and what was the prescription the
prescription that um the thing that he
got i was just thinking like how much
i've always admired james as a tennis
player i've also also liked james
because he's funny and we laugh together
and
um
we we have good conversations but i've
always admired him as a tennis player
but when he was talking about his
experience with
uh this cop and and how he was so
persistent how james
didn't relent you know and used his
resources
to
move the needle uh even if it was just a
little bit and and that the instead of
being instead of being allowed to sue
the police department which i'm sure he
could have he could have made a lot of
money but it wasn't about that it wasn't
about that it was about getting measures
in place that that ensure that this
would be harder for it happening that
that ensured that this wouldn't happen
again or at least it'd be harder for it
to happen again
that's no that's true that's something i
i that's true that's like noble he's on
he's honorable there's something that
always struck me as
super honorable about him and it's funny
we were watching that lance armstrong
documentary the other night and
and uh and it just struck me how
different and then after having heard
this interview
just how different
james blake is as a
man as a as an athlete and
and what a hard worker he is and i would
in a million years i couldn't see him
ever cheating at his sport you know what
i mean oh my god there's just something
he's like the ultimate gentleman yeah
he's like integrity truly honorable true
can true convictions he was raised right
yeah he was genuinely he was raised
right so it's and also very impressive
that he so shout out to betty really
yeah shout out to her um and also very
impressive his golden girl's knowledge
most importantly yeah well let's talk
about that real
real important that's right yeah he
loved and i love that his his wife uh i
don't like that she called him a nerd
but i liked that like it made sense why
we were friends like oh i'm asking about
it if knowing a lot about the golden
girls makes you a nerd a sign me out oh
my god yeah let's read a letter okay
this one's from cat with two t's cats
it's pronounced cat okay
uh subject would you rather read this
email or throw it away
read it yeah well we've just answered
that
hi justin christian your show is a
bright shiny spot in this cloudy time
thank you kat
literally it is a cloudy day today
i started listening to you guys through
armchair of course thanks dax but i'm
hooked and can't get enough as far as
quarantine not much has changed for
myself or my husband but my
eight-year-old is going bonkers
not seeing his friends or teachers oh i
bet god for an eight-year-old i'd be
climbing the walls
i've become his new best friend well
that's good he'll call me into his room
and while he's sitting at one end of his
bed pat the other side and say you want
to talk ah that's really sweet of course
i want to talk i just let him babble on
about whatever it is eight-year-olds
think is interesting that's awesome then
we usually get into a talk about our
feelings it's so sad to see such a young
person be so depressed to all the moms
dads and guardians and miscellaneous out
there you're doing fine and there's
light at the end of this tunnel i love
all your check-ins with jerry dr dave
and most of all your grandma
hear that jerry
your voice and tone sound just like my
yaya greek for grandma but you probably
know that
i didn't know it was greek i've heard
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i love that band
oh sorry who died four years ago or yaya
died four years ago um she was my bestie
so i love hearing those old lady
mannerisms ah thanks kat
before my would you rather i'd like to
give a shout out to the doc at inwood
cool the owners do a fundraiser every
tuesday during the summer and give a
percentage of their proceeds to the
organizat organization that has signed
up that week they've helped great causes
all over our community their food is
delicious and the staff is fun awesome
okay that's the doc
at inwood why why does that sound so
familiar it does sound familiar yeah uh
here's the would you rather
the wyr which i have to really think
about eat only one food for the rest of
your life i.e steak but no eggs or
potatoes or sides for every meal or
have your worst enemy feed you every
meal
while singing your least favorite song
oh god wow
that is good i'm trying to think of my
least wait can it be any food if you
pick one food i guess i guess so yeah
because the first one's about limiting
the food the first one is eat only one
food for the rest of your life i eat
steak but no eggs every meal oh you i
mean
well let's just zoom in yeah yeah
three steaks
in a month
um
remember that guy that we worked with
who like eight we were working and
christian i did a movie in new orleans
and we were
uh this one guy was like bragging about
all the great meat
he felt like all the great barbecue and
beer joints he found oh so gross he like
had charcuterie for breakfast yes and he
and like oh you got to try this one's a
little hoppier than the other that's all
he wanted to talk about with this
producer in like a couple weeks in we
were like where's so-and-so they said oh
he uh
he has gout he's laid up
he got gout from eating meat gross by
the way speaking of meat uh we made
beyond beyond burgers last night i made
some they were delicious delicious it's
really gonna help with my meatless
monday i might switch over to i might do
a couple days of meat it's gonna help
with the phasing out meat part of my
life i think i love those shout out to
beyond burgers okay um this is tough uh
i would have my worst enemy feed me
everything
every meal well okay i get used to the
song and the person i don't have a worst
enemy
uh but i i'm thinking of someone i
really dislike me too and um
and i'm also thinking about my preferred
thinking i'm also thinking about my
least favorite song what's your least
favorite song
um you don't know it oh wait wait wait
um think about it
oh no that's up there i don't know i
know it i know it uh it's not um the
play is it back to town it is yeah
i hate the boys are back in town so if
this person i'm thinking of is yes you
just wrote these two
if this person i'm thinking of is
serving me
a variety of food
while singing that song you get as long
as i don't have to interact with him or
have the meal with him and yeah right
after he delivers me the food he just
poof disappears oh i think i see i read
it more as he's actually feeding it oh
like baby birding me well not spitting
it out into your mouth oh actually
feeding it into my mouth oh boy well
maybe not i don't know i wish cad and
clarified because this is a good one all
right let's say he's just serving it to
you because then then i pick that option
as long as he can poof disappear and i
don't have to like
read it with him
okay
uh
that way i don't have to spend every
night with him like hang out with him
he's just in my life all the time yeah
but if he's just magically dropping a
plate in front of him um i if i would
choose that i'm
making an assumption about cats would
you rather but i think part of it is you
have to hang out with him while you're
eating the meal fine maybe while i'm
eating the meal that's one thing but
after the meal is over i couldn't do and
also if he's spoon-feeding me i think i
would still pick that
i might draw the line at baby burning
i don't want him dropping food as well
but i don't want to have the same meal
same meal
that would stink it would stink yeah and
i would imagine over time and i know
this isn't the point but you would
probably get used because he would be he
would i might start liking him exactly
you might start liking each other it
might be like a nice thing right i
picked that option me too because it's
also a
it's a it's you could argue it's a
bigger pain in the ass for him
you know i haven't considered his
feelings yeah but he's got to sing this
song
yes you just honestly it's
lyrics it's all over the place
they went to rabbit all the old man
crazy
it is such a dumb song the lyrics are
yeah everyone do yourself a favor and
listen to the lyrics of the boys are
back in town
they are the dumbest way not many
dumbest lyrics in any song you've ever
heard who sings it uh i forgot i
remember when you like pointed that out
to me and i started i hadn't really
taken notice of the liz uh
guess who just got back today
do you know the next line no
them wild-eyed boys that had been away
haven't changed that much to say but man
i still think them cats are crazy it's
nonsense they were asking if you were
around how you was where you could be
found told him you were living downtown
driving all the old men crazy
the boys are backing down the boys are
back you know that chick that used to
dance a lot every night she'd be on the
floor shaking what she got
when i say she was cool she was red hot
i mean she was steaming
and that time over at johnny's place
well this chick got up and she's she
slapped johnny's face she slapped johnny
all over the place man we just we just
fell about the place if that chick don't
want to know forget her
so poorly written do she all right well
thank you cat
thanks for the letter and thanks for
this looks like glorifying violence
friday night they'll be dressed to kill
down at dino's bar and grill the drink
will flow in the blood we'll see it's
just such a douchey song and if the boys
want to fight you better let them jesus
[ __ ] that song okay um thank you kat and
thank you for the would you rather that
was a good one lizzie and um
thank you
oh and let's and by the quarantine
episode oh yeah okay a little note about
the quarantine episodes uh it looks like
we are going to
stop doing them regularly a big thank
you from us to james blake our pal
and uh and betty blake uh for doing a
hell of a job and to tom blake for being
a really good brother tom blake's a
great guy too that was cool huh yeah
i remember watching the blake matches on
tv and his cheering section was called
the j block do you remember that
and it was always people i recognized
from high school and yeah and tom his
brother was always front and center in
the j block he was always right there
cheering him on that made me that really
made me happy to hear him talk about him
and also shout out to brian rau our our
mutual friend for introducing me to
james and giving me a venue to get drunk
for the first time yes me too
uh and james and now all of us uh in
fairfield um
and shout out to fairfield uh a really
great place to
grow up in and if you live there i hope
you think about what james said and uh
think about some of the your own actions
and
how like we've been doing this week how
we may have been complicit in this
system that we've got to change
and we will see you all next week yes
thank you for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by you christian long
and her over in la megan monaco uh
senior producers michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louis
and bernan lopez for who wandering
thanks for listening
[Music]
i had the pleasure of playing on the
high school tennis team with james
and uh for two years i got to see him
dominate everybody that he ever played
and
always do so with you know a smile on
his face and
i would say the the highlight of my
illustrious tennis career came one day
in
practice when uh for some reason the
coach had us play each other
and
i happened to get a single game off of
him meaning that he beat me 6-1 in the
set
and even doing that i have no idea how
it happened i think i hit a couple lucky
serves and he maybe broke a string on
one shot or something and
but anyway i uh i got a single game and
from that moment forward i got to tell
anyone who would listen that
i got a game off of james blake and uh
including you know when we were watching
him on tv in the u.s open
uh
playing andre agassi i think i told my
soon-to-be wife that and i'm not sure
that she fully understands
what that means in this context but
i haven't you know taken the time to
necessarily explain it to her fully but
uh james was always a good sport about
it he let me kind of uh
have my little moment of glory there and
you know james is
just one of those uh one of those people
that you're kind of lucky to
to know uh to have known and i feel kind
of privileged to have known him when he
was a young guy but it's been awesome to
see him
and the success that he's had over the
years and just the person that he's
always been has been really great to uh
to have him as part of my life
you